[Music]
we will discuss the role of the DevOps
engineer and how you can step up in your
present role to become a DevOps engineer
we'll also see the ongoing trend in need
for organizations to move to DevOps
so who exactly is a DevOps engineer
DevOps engineer is a new role that
software organizations are creating
within organizations that are adopting
DevOps and the various tools within the
DevOps toolkit those organizations need
professionals who know and understand
these tools DevOps engineers work with
various tools to implement continuous
integration and continuous deployment
familiarity with tools like git Jenkins
teamcity puppet Chef ansible kubernetes
Amazon AWS cloud cucumber sonar Nagios
to name a few can catapult your journey
to become a DevOps engineer so why do we
need DevOps Engineers organizations that
are using DevOps are overwhelmingly
high-functioning they deploy code 30
times faster and 30 times more
frequently and 50% fewer of their
deployments fail after they began using
DevOps software isn't written the old
way anymore where it used to be written
from scratch which is a highly complex
time-consuming process creating new
software products now is often a matter
of choosing the right open source
software and bringing them together
while writing some code the complexity
of today's software lies less in writing
the code and more in ensuring that the
new software will work across a range of
operating systems and platforms right
away similarly builds testing
deployments are now done much more
frequently and that is possible only if
developers communicate early and
regularly with the operations teams and
the operations team in turn brings their
knowledge of the production environment
to design and testing stages of the
software project what kind of skills
does the DevOps engineer need you need
soft skills a very broad understanding
of tools and technologies software and
infrastructure security infrastructure
automation tools and also testing you
need your customer comes first mindset
you also need skills such as
collaboration flexibility awareness of
the network and of course to be able to
think and see the big picture for a
DevOps engineer to be successful you
must possess strong communication skills
similar to agile development teams soft
skills are incredibly important not just
for the individual engineer but also in
making the organizational cultural shift
to implementing and then standardizing
DevOps since new technologies and tools
continuously crop up on the DevOps
landscape it's highly important for a
good DevOps engineer to have a broad
understanding of those in the following
areas the source control like git
bitbucket subversion continuous
integration like jenkins bamboo vs TS
infrastructure automation like puppet
container concepts like docker
deployment automation or orchestration
like jenkins octopus deploy container
concepts like lv XD or docker
orchestration like kubernetes me soz
swarm cloud like AWS asher Google cloud
and OpenStack a great DevOps engineer is
always curious and open to learning new
things he or she must constantly ask
questions and then listen to answers to
generate new ideas and welcome new
challenges while combining development
and operations is a great way to
streamline development and deployment of
code the faster cycle means that
vulnerabilities can be introduced into
code much faster than previously
therefore DevOps engineers must be able
to write secure code to protect
applications from attack as well as
defend against common cyber security
vulnerabilities DevOps professionals
even though they don't need to be expert
security professionals can benefit
tremendously from having software
security training as in so many tech
environments a key element of DevOps is
automation a lot of the manual tasks
performed by more traditional system
administrators and engineering roles can
be automated by using scripting
languages like Python Ruby bash shell
and nodejs
this will ensure consistent performance
of manual tasks by removing the human
component and allowing teams to spend
and save time on more of the broader
goals of the team and the company so the
DevOps engineer
possess the ability to use automation
technology and tools at any level from
requirements to development to testing
and all the way to operations automation
is driven by testing so strong testing
skills are needed to be a successful
DevOps engineer when proper tests are in
place you can rest assured that each
function is doing what it was written to
do from all stages from development to
deployment you can run tests to make
sure that the entire system is
interacting and it has all the new
features now first and foremost the
DevOps engineer always cares about
delivering value to his or her customers
and wants to understand and measure how
the work is moving the needle while
DevOps engineers are not typically
external facing roles developers QA
customer success project management
business leaders are all their clients
by caring about the outcome as opposed
to their part of the supply chain
they'll have the right instincts with
regard to how to optimize for end-to-end
success strong DevOps managers must be
great team members and help relieve
bottlenecks by assisting co-workers as
necessary any problem in the project is
everyone's problem and a great engineer
always makes those around them better a
great DevOps engineer works in small
batches so that the others can do their
work more easily from performing code
reviews to writing acceptance tests the
key basically is to have empathy for
others so that the entire team can move
more quickly
a successful DevOps culture demands
flexibility multitasking is another key
for a DevOps engineer the DevOps
engineer must be network aware the end
objective of any DevOps project is to be
able to successfully deliver an
application to the end user who will
consume it and use it that involves the
network a good DevOps engineer will
recognize that you have to account for
the network in your to design your
planning and your testing while many
DevOps engineers are excellent software
engineers they sometimes lack the
ability to look at the big picture and
identify what makes sense for the client
because DevOps combines the needs and
wants of multidisciplinary teams and
applications a successful DevOps
engineer can't lose sight of the big
picture for DevOps and digital
transformation at the enterprise level
especially in a large organization now
this helps avoid creating contention
points and constraints that can carry
from one project to another so our
DevOps engineers a new team within
organizations a DevOps engineer
basically can be anyone who has had
software development or software
deployment production monitoring
knowledge and is also adept with newer
automation tools it can be a Java
developer who knows how to work at
Jenkins pipeline to create automated
builds using maven it's a manual tester
who writes TDD test cases forge a unit
or configures sonar quality gates for
software delivery it can be a systems
operations engineer who understands the
architecture of a software and helps the
team set up a performance test suite for
testing in summary it's a software
professional who understands all aspects
of software development and delivery
whether its system architecture
deployment pipelines or instance
management DevOps engineers came in at
number three on various job portals in
America in 2017 the DevOps engineer
position grew by a 106 percent in the
last few years and the DevOps engineer
position boasts an annual salary of one
hundred twenty three thousand one
hundred sixty five dollars so that is
how much DevOps
Engineer jobs are in demand and how much
had they're expected to grow a survey of
252 Gartner research circle members
showed that 38% of those were already
using DevOps in 2016 and an additional
35% have plans to implement DevOps in
2017 that is over 70% of the world's
entire IT market we are talking about
and the Gartner and State of DevOps
report for 2017 summarizes it all for us
saying that by 2020 half of the CIOs of
the world who have not transformed their
team's capabilities will be displaced
from their organization's digital
leadership teams
hey once become an expert in cloud
computing then subscribe to simpler
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos turn it up and get certified
in cloud computing click here